हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही
है? प्लीज बता दीजिए। सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है?
मैं अच्छा हूं दोस्तों। आप लोग कैसे हो?
यह बताइए।
आप लोग बताइए कैसे हो?
तो सबको डेफोनिक्स एकडमी पर मजा आ रहा है?
ओके थैंक यू अगर सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है तो सबको डेफोनिक्स एकडमी पर मजा आ
रहा है सीखने को मिल रहा है
सीखने को मिल रहा है अभी जो आपको
प्लेलिस्ट मिली है
फ्री एथिकल हैकिंग की एक पार्ट वन जो 5.5
आवर्स की जो एक प्लेलिस्ट है अच्छी लगी
सबको
रिवीजन हुआ आपका? किस-किस ने देखी यहां
पर?
जितने स्टूडेंट यहां पर प्रेजेंट है,
किस-किस ने वो सीरीज देखी है? बताना जरा।
यहां से किस-किस ने देखी है वो?
दो मिनट का वेट करते हैं। बाकी स्टूडेंट्स
को आने देते हैं। उसके बाद क्लास को
स्टार्ट करेंगे। तब तक के लिए थोड़ी सी
बातें कर लेते हैं। तो वह सीरीज
किस-किस ने देखी है? ओके। मोहित ने भी
देखी है। नूड न्यूड ने भी देखी है। ओके
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। अगर आपका फर्स्ट सेशन
है तो डोंट वरी कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है।
मोहित कौन सी क्लास?
तो उस सीरीज में क्या है ना कि आपका बेसिक
पूरा रिवीजन हो जाएगा क्योंकि मैं अपनी
कुछ क्लासेस में पहले वो सारी चीजें कवर
कर चुका हूं। वो आपको एक क्विक रिवीजन का
काम करेगी। वो सीरीज आपके लिए। बाकी आपको
डिटेल्स में जो भी कुछ सीखना है उस सीरीज
में जो भी चीजें डिस्कशन की गई होंगी और
की जाने वाली होंगी उनसे रिलेटेड कुछ भी
आपको डिटेल में सीखना है उनसे कई ज्यादा
इस सीरीज में है क्योंकि वो आपको बेसिक
बताएगी। आपको एक क्विक रिवीजन करवा रही
है। वह आपका एक इंट्रो है कि एथिकल हैकिंग
सीरीज में एक क्विक रिवीजन करवा दिया गया
आपका। बट जब आप डीईएई को बिल्कुल डे वन से
देखना स्टार्ट करोगे तो आपको खुद से पता
चल जाएगा कि डीएई क्या चीज है। डीएई कोई
आउटडेटेड
चीज नहीं है। यह मत सोचना कि अगर लास्ट
ईयर स्टार्ट हुई थी तो अभी यह आउटडेटेड हो
गई होगी। नहीं, यह आउटडेटेड नहीं हुई है।
ओके? यह आउटडेटेड नहीं हुई है। यह चीज
ध्यान में रखो। तो
चलिए फिर एक काम करते हैं। सेशन को
स्टार्ट करने करते हैं। देखिए प्लीज आप
क्या पूछ रहे हो योरसेल्फ 7869 आई डोंट नो
कि आप क्या कहने की कोशिश कर रहे हो। मुझे
समझ में नहीं आ रहा। तो प्लीज मेरी
रिक्वेस्ट है कि मैसेज से कमेंट सेक्शन को
ना भें क्योंकि किसी की जो
रिक्वेस्ट पर्सनल रिक्वेस्ट होगी या किसी
को कुछ पूछना होगा तो उनका क्वेश्चन क्या
हो जाएगा? हाइड हो जाएगा। हम देख नहीं
पाएंगे। तो थोड़ा सा बता देता हूं आपको
प्रीवियस क्लासेस में हमने अभी तक बहुत
सारी चीजें डिस्कस की हैं कि
जैसे कि हमने स्टार्ट किया था क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक से क्योंकि जो पार्ट चल रहा है
क्लास 60 से यह एक्सटर्नल पेन टेस्टिंग चल
रही है। उससे पहले हमने जितनी भी चीजें
डिस्कस की थी क्लास 60 59 तक वहां पर थी
इंटरनल पेन टेस्टिंग। मतलब आप नेटवर्क के
अंदर हो तो आप पेन टेस्टिंग कैसे कर सकते
हो? वह भी कंप्लीट पोर्शन नहीं है। उसमें
बहुत कुछ बचा हुआ है जो अभी हम कवर करने
वाले हैं।
उसके बाद हमने स्टार्ट की एक्सटर्नल पेन
टेस्टिंग। एक्सटर्नल पेन टेस्टिंग की मतलब
आपके पास कोई भी नॉलेज नहीं है। आपको जस्ट
एक IPपी एड्रेस की नॉलेज है या आपको एक
डोमेन का नाम पता है या आपको टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का नाम पता है। तो आप कैसे
उसको हैक करोगे? कैसे उस पे उसको टारगेट
करोगे? उसके बारे में आपको सिखाया जा रहा
है। तो उसमें सबसे पहले हमने डिस्कशन किया
था। हमने डिस्कशन किया था कि
हम क्लाइंट साइड अटैक को पूरी तरह से
डिस्कस करेंगे। तो क्लाइंट साइड अटैक सबसे
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक के अंदर एक सबसे मेजर
चीज होती है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। तो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग के बारे में हमने डिस्कशन
किया। अब सोशल इंजीनियरिंग सही से परफॉर्म
करने के लिए हमने लास्ट क्लास में जो चीज
पढ़ी थी वह थी रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट एंड
वेपनाइजेशन। तो उसका बेसिक मैंने कवर किया
कि रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट का मतलब क्या होता
है और वेपनाइजेशन का मतलब क्या होता है
क्योंकि दोनों टर्म आप समझते हो एक है
लेकिन ये दोनों टर्म एक नहीं है क्योंकि
एग्जुकेशन फेज से पहले यूज़ होने वाली
दोनों ही टर्म है तो रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट और
वेपनाइजेशन को बहुत अच्छे से मैंने दो
क्लास में डिफरेंशिएट करके आपको बताया था
तो अगर वहां से आप देखोगे तो वहां से आपको
पता चल जाएगा कि कैसे अह क्या मतलब है
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट का। तो आज हम स्टार्ट
करने जा रहे हैं मैक से क्योंकि हम मैंने
जैसे आपको बताया था जो क्लास 60 में ही कि
हमारा टारगेट क्या रहेगा अभी स्टार्टिंग
के कुछ क्लासेस में उसके बाद हम अपना नया
इस पे
अब बोले तो हम अपने रोड मैप बताएंगे या नई
चीजें इसमें बताएंगे कि अभी अगली कुछ
क्लासेस में क्या होने वाला है। तो अभी तक
जो हमने डिस्कस किया था क्लास 60 में कि
मैं आपको क्या-क्या पढ़ाने वाला हूं आने
वाली कुछ 10 15 20 क्लासेस में वो अभी तक
कंप्लीट नहीं हुआ है। तो उसी का एक पार्ट
है। मैंने आपको बताया था। आप इसको समझ
सकते हो कि पेलोड डेवलपमेंट या एक्सप्लोर
डेवलपमेंट या फिर आप समझ सकते हो इस चीज
को कि हम जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस होता है जो
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड होते हैं हमारे जो
एक्सेल्स है उसके अंदर हम अपने पेलोड को
कैसे छुपा सकते हैं? उस चीज की ट्रेनिंग
चल रही है। तो उसके लिए आपको क्या सीखना
पड़ेगा? मैक डेवलपमेंट। तो आज हम बात
करेंगे उसके फंडामेंटल्स की। आज और कल हम
बात करने वाले हैं
इनके फंडामेंटल्स की। मैं बताऊंगा अभी वही
क्लास स्टार्ट करने वाला हूं। फंडामेंटल्स
कवर करेंगे दो क्लासेस में। उसके बाद इसका
प्रैक्टिकल भी स्टार्ट होगा। अभी तक
थ्योरी चल रही थी। अभी प्रैक्टिकल्स भी
होगा। तो चलिए हम सेशन को स्टार्ट करते
हैं। ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे। तो
टुडे
तो एक बार मुझे बताइए। सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है? प्लीज जल्दी से बता
दीजिए। जल्दी से बता दीजिए। वेरी गुड
इवनिंग। वेरी गुड इवनिंग। सभी की गुड
इवनिंग। मेरी तरफ से भी आपकी तरफ से भी
गुड इवनिंग। एंड अभी सब कुछ बता दूंगा कि
क्या चीजें होती हैं। वीबीए होता क्या है।
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है? लाउड एंड
क्लियर है ना?
ओके थैंक यू। तो टुडे वी आर गोइंग टू
स्टार्ट विद ए वेरीेंट टॉपिक दैट इज वीबीए
मैक फंडामेंटल्स। वीबीए मैक फंडामेंटल्स।
अभी सबसे पहले समझते हैं वीबीए क्या है?
सबसे पहले समझते हैं वीबीए क्या होता है
या किस चीज का नाम है वीबीए
किस चीज का नाम है वीबीए
वीबीए विजुअल बेसिक्स फॉर एप्लीकेशन इज ए
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज डेवलप्ड बाय
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट फॉर ऑटोमेटिंग टास्क एंड
एक्सटेंडिंग द फंक्शनलिटी ऑफ इट्स ऑफिस
सूट ऑफ एप्लीकेशनेशंस इंक्लूडिंग एक्सेल
वर्ड पावर पॉइंट एक्सेस एंड आउटलुक अभी
अभी ये चीज आपको नहीं समझ में आएगी। तो
वीबीए की फुल फॉर्म है विजुअल बेसिक्स फॉर
एप्लीकेशन। विजुअल बेसिक्स फॉर एप्लीकेशन।
इट इज ए प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज डेवलप्ड
बाय Microsoft।
यह Microsoft के द्वारा डेवलप की गई एक
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज है। जिसका प्राइमरी
गोल है Microsoft Office जो सूट है, जैसे
कि जो Microsoft Office सूट के अंदर
क्या-क्या आता है? जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट Office
सूट है उसके अंदर क्या-क्या आता है आपका
एक्सेल वर्ड पावर पॉइंट एक्सेस और आउटलुक
उसके अंदर जो भी टास्क है उनको ऑटोमेट
परफॉर्म करना और उसकी फंक्शनैलिटी को
एक्सटेंड करना मैं रिपीट बोल रहा हूं कि
यह जो वीबीए है जिसको हम बोलते हैं विजुअल
बेसिक्स फॉर एप्लीकेशन यह माइक्रोसॉफ्ट के
द्वारा डेवलप की गई एक प्रोग्रामिंग
लैंग्वेज है। इसका प्राइमरी गोल है Excel
वर्ड पावर पॉइंट एक्सेस और आउटलुक के अंदर
टास्क को ऑटोमेट करना और उनकी फंक्शनैलिटी
को एक्सटेंड करना टास्क को ऑटोमेट करना और
उनकी फंक्शनैलिटी को क्या करना एक्सटेंड
करना बढ़ाना तो नेक्स्ट पॉइंट पर चलते हैं
वीबीए वीबीए स्क्रिप्टिंग कैन बी यूज्ड टू
ऑटोमेट प्रोसेस इंटरेक्टिंग विद द विंडोज
एपीआई एंड इंप्लीमेंट यूजर डिफाइंड एंड
फंक्शनंस इट आल्सो इनेबल्स यू इट आल्सो
इनेबल्स यू टू मैनपुलेट द यूजर इंटरफेस
फीचर्स ऑफ द होस्ट एप्लीकेशन।
देखिए वीबी वीबीएस स्क्रिप्टिंग के जरिए
आप रिपीिटिव मैनुअल टास्क को ऑटोमेट कर
सकते हैं। किसको? रिपीटेटिव मैनुअल टास्क
को ऑटोमेट कर सकते हैं। Windows एपीआई के
साथ इंटैक्ट कर सकते हैं। कस्टम यूजर
डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस क्रिएट कर सकते हो। और
होस्ट एप्लीकेशन की जो यूडर इंटरफेस है जो
यूआई है उसको मैनपुलेट और कस्टमाइज कर
सकते हो। तो इस लाइन का क्या मतलब है?
वीबीएस स्क्रिप्टिंग कैन बी यूज्ड टू
ऑटोमेट प्रोसेससेस इंटरेक्टिंग विद द
Windows एपीआई एंड इंप्लीमेंट यूजर
डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस। इट आल्सो इनेबल्स यू टू
मैनपुलेट द यूआई फीचर्स ऑफ होस्ट
एप्लीकेशन। मतलब मैं दोबारा रिपीट कर रहा
हूं। इस लाइन का मतलब है कि वीबीएस
स्क्रिप्टिंग के जरिए आप रिपीिटेटिव
मैनुअल टास्क को ऑटोमेट कर सकते हो।
Windows एपीआई के साथ इंटैक्ट कर सकते हो।
कस्टम यूजर डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस क्रिएट कर
सकते हो और होस्ट एप्लीकेशन के यूआई को
मैनपुलेट और कस्टमाइज कर सकते हो। अब
मैंने आपको चार चीजें बताई। यहां पे
डिस्कस की है कि आप रिपीिटेटिव मैनुअल
टास्क को ऑटोमेट कर सकते हो। दूसरी चीज
Windows एपीआई के साथ इंटैक्ट कर सकते हो।
तीसरी अपने खुद के कस्टम यूजर डिफाइंड
फंक्शन डिफाइन कर सकते हो और चौथी चीज मैं
आपको क्या बताई यहां पर आप जो होस्ट
एप्लीकेशन है होस्ट एप्लीकेशन कौन सी है
आपकी एक्सेल आपकी वर्ड है आपका आउटलुक है
या एक्सेस है पावर पॉइंट हो गया उसकी जो
यूआई है उसको क्या कर सकते हो आप मैनपुलेट
और कस्टमाइज कर सकते हो बेसिकली आप उसको
कस्टमाइज कर सकते हो तो ये चार पॉइंट
मैंने आपको बताए तो इन चारों को मैं आपको
डिटेल में समझाता हूं कि चारों पॉइंट का
मतलब क्या है क्योंकि अभी आपको समझ में
नहीं आया होगा। तो सबसे पहले हम डिस्कस
करते हैं पॉइंट नंबर वन जैसा कि मैंने
आपको बोला था कि इस वीबीएस स्क्रिप्टिंग
के जरिए आप क्या कर सकते हो? रिपीटेटिव
मैनुअल टास्क को ऑटोमेट कर सकते हो। मतलब
व्हेन ए यूजर परफॉर्म द सेम टास्क डेली और
रिपीटेडली इन microsoft ऑफिस वीबीए
प्रोवाइड द कैपेबिलिटी टू ऑटोमेट द एंटायर
प्रोसेस विद ए सिंगल क्लिक। इसका मतलब
क्या है कि जब भी कोई यूजर Microsoft
Office में एक ही काम को डेली या बार-बार
मैनुअली परफॉर्म करता है जो काफी बोरिंग
और टाइम कंज्यूमिंग होता है तो वीबीए उस
प्रोसेस को एक सिंगल क्लिक पर ऑटोमेटिकली
परफॉर्म करने की कैपेबिलिटी प्रोवाइड करता
है। आई एम रिपीटिंग अगेन। इस लाइन का मतलब
है कि जब भी कोई यूजर Microsoft Office के
अंदर कोई ऑफिस के अंदर एक ही काम को डेली
या रिपीटेडली करता है। बार-बार मैनुअली कर
रहा है। उस उस पूरे प्रोसेस को एक सिंगल
क्लिक पर ऑटोमेटिकली परफॉर्म करने की
कैपेबिलिटी प्रोवाइड करता है। कौन? वीबीए।
कौन प्रोवाइड करता है उसको? वीबीए। तो एक
एग्जांपल समझते हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल एक
फाइनेंस मैनेजर है। फॉर एग्जांपल एक
फाइनेंस मैनेजर है और वो क्या करता है?
उसे हर रोज शाम को एक बहुत ही बोरिंग काम
करना पड़ता है। वो क्या और वो क्या काम
है? वो हर रोज अलग-अलग डिपार्टमेंट्स की
50 अलग-अलग एक्सेल फाइल को क्या करता है?
एक-एक करके ओपन करता है। उनका डाटा
मैनुअली कट, कॉपी, पेस्ट करता है। एक
मास्टर समरी शीट में। ठीक है? क्या करता
है? उनका डाटा को मैनुअली कॉपी और पेस्ट
करके क्या करता है? एक मास्टर समरी शीट
है। उसमें क्या करता है? पेस्ट करता है।
उस डाटा को जोड़ता है। फिर उसका एक पीडीएफ
बनाता है। पीडीएफ बनाकर मैनेजमेंट को मेल
करता है। डेली का काम उसका क्या करता है
कि वह अलग-अलग डिपार्टमेंट से एक्सेल फाइल
को कलेक्ट करता है। कलेक्ट करने के बाद
उसको रीड करता है। उसके डेटा को मैनुअली
कॉपी करता है। उसके बाद फिर एक समरी शीट
है। उसके अंदर उसको पेस्ट करता है। पेस्ट
करने के बाद उसका एक पीडीएफ बनाता है।
पीडीएफ बनाने के बाद उसको एज एन अटैचमेंट
मेल जो मैनेजमेंट टीम है उसको भेजता है।
अभी यहां पर रिस्क क्या है या कोई रिस्क
है भी या नहीं है? तो यहां पर रिस्क कितना
है? यहां पर रिस्क है अगर एक छोटी सी भी
कॉपी पेस्ट की मिस्टेक अगर कोई भी एक छोटी
सी कॉपी पेस्ट मिस्टेक है या कोई भी बाय
मिस्टेक गलत फार्मूला सेट हो गया उस
यूज़र्स के द्वारा तो क्या होगा? उसकी जो
पूरी फाइनेंशियल रिपोर्ट है वह खराब हो
जाएगी। ठीक है? उसकी जो पूरी फाइनेंशियल
रिपोर्ट है वह खराब हो सकती है। और सबसे
बड़ी बात कि यह पूरा प्रोसेस करने में कि
अलग-अलग डिपार्टमेंट से
एक्सेल शीट आने के बाद उसे डाटा रीड करना
रीड करके कॉपी पेस्ट करना उसके बाद
मैनेजमेंट को भेजना। उस उसमें उसके डेली 2
से 3 घंटे लगते हैं। उसमें उसके डेली 2 से
3 घंटे लगते हैं। और यही काम अगर हम क्या
करें? अगर यही काम अगर हम वीबीए से करें
तो यही काम वीबीए से हम सिर्फ 5 सेकंड में
कर देंगे। ठीक है? यही काम वीबीए से 5
सेकंड में हो सकता है। कैसे? आपको क्या
करना है? आपको अपने एक्सेल शीट में एक बटन
बनाना होगा। उसके लिए फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे
बटन का नाम ले दिया हमने जनरेट समरी। उसके
लिए आपको क्या करना है? एक बटन बनाना
पड़ेगा और
उसके पीछे एक वीबीए में कोड लिखना होगा।
और जैसे ही यूजर श्याम को जो हम जो उसका
मैनुअल टास्क था वह परफॉर्म करने के लिए
उस बटन पर क्लिक करता है तो बैकग्राउंड
में जो वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट है वह क्या
करेगी? कुछ ही सेकंड में उन सारे 50 जो 50
एक्सेल फाइल थी उनको ऑटोमेटिकली रीड
करेगी। उसके बाद उसके डाटा को कैलकुलेट
करके एक समरी शीट में ऑटोमेटिकली मर्ज कर
देगी। मर्ज करने के बाद उस पूरे डाटा का
एक क्लीन पीडीएफ रिपोर्ट जनरेट करेगी और
जनरेट करने के बाद ऑटोमेटिकली आउटलुक के
जरिए उनको उनकी जो मैनेजमेंट है उसको मेल
सेंड कर देगी विद इन जस्ट ए 5 सेकंड। जो
काम आप मैनुअली कर रहे थे जस्ट आपने क्या
किया एक बटन पर क्लिक किया एक्सेल के अंदर
जनरेट समरी उसने उन सारी 50 फाइल एक्सेल
फाइल को रीड किया रीड करने के बाद डाटा को
क्या किया कैलकुलेट किया कैलकुलेट करने
समरी शीट खुद से बनाई उसको पीडीएफ में
कन्वर्ट किया पीडीएफ में कन्वर्ट करने के
बाद मैनेजमेंट को मेल भी खुद ही कर दिया
जस्ट ए सिंगल क्लिक रिजल्ट क्या आ रहा जो
काम करने में डेली उस मैनेजर को 2 घंटे
लगते थे अब वह सिर्फ 5 सेकंड में हो जाता
है बिना किसी ह्यूमन इंटरवेंशन के और एरर
फ्री। क्योंकि जब वीबीए कोड लिखा जाएगा
वीबीए में जो प्रोग्रामिंग की जाएगी इनके
अंदर वो पूरी एक ही बार में सोच समझ कर की
जाएगी ना कि डेली कोई फार्मूला चेंज करना।
डेली कुछ करना। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? पॉइंट
नंबर वन सबको क्लियर है? पॉइंट नंबर वन
सबको क्लियर है एवरीवन?
पॉइंट नंबर वन सबको क्लियर है? बताओ।
पॉइंट नंबर वन सबको क्लियर है? जल्दी से
बताओ।
अब मुझे यह मत बोलना कि सर एथिकल हैकिंग
की क्लासेस में यह क्या चीज समझा रहे हो?
क्योंकि जब तक आपको यह नहीं पता होगा कि
वीबीए क्या होता है? मैक क्या होता है?
ठीक है? बेसिक्स उसके फंडामेंटल्स आपको
नहीं पता होगा। डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट क्या
होता है और इसको फिर क्लाइंट सेट अटैक में
कैसे यूज किया जाता है। जब तक आपको यह
नहीं पता होगा यू कांट डू एनीथिंग। आप
अपना पेलोड रेडी नहीं कर सकते। आप अपनी
स्क्रिप्ट रेडी नहीं कर सकते।
चलिए तो अभी पॉइंट नंबर टू पर चलते हैं।
तो पॉइंट नंबर टू पर मैंने आपको क्या
बताया था कि आप वीबीएस स्क्रिप्टिंग की
हेल्प से क्या कर सकते हो? Windows एपीआई
के साथ इंटैक्ट कर सकते हो। Windows एपीआई
के साथ इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हो। अब Windows
एपीआई के साथ इंटरेक्ट करने का मतलब क्या
है? इसका मतलब क्या है? और कैसे कर सकते
हैं। ओके अब इसका मतलब क्या है और कैसे कर
सकते हैं। तो वीबीए ठीक है तो सबसे पहले
हम समझते हैं वीबीए वाले पार्ट को। सबसे
पहले हम समझते हैं इस पार्ट को। वीबीए
वाले पार्ट को। ओके? इस पार्ट को समझते
हैं। उसके बाद में नेक्स्ट पार्ट बताऊंगा।
बाय डिफॉल्ट वीबीए इज लिमिटेड टू
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट Office एप्लीकेशन सच एज
एक्सेल वर्ड एंड पावर पॉइंट। मतलब यह है
वीबीए बाय डिफॉल्ट एक घर के अंदर रहने
वाला बच्चा है। ठीक है? वीबीए बाय डिफॉल्ट
एक घर के अंदर रहने वाले बच्चे की तरह है
जिसका पूरा कंट्रोल सिर्फ Microsoft
Office के Microsoft Office जैसे Excel
वर्ड Powpoin के अंदर तक ही सीमित है।
लिमिटेड है। आई एम रिपीटिंग अगेन कि मैं
बता रहा हूं जो वीबीए है बाय डिफॉल्ट एक
घर के एक ऐसे बच्चे की तरह है जिसका पूरा
जो कंट्रोल है वह लिमिटेड है। उसी घर तक
ही सीमित है और वह घर कौन सा है? वीबीए के
लिए माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस। माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस
में क्या है आपका? Excel, वर्ड और पावर
पॉइंट। लेकिन वहीं पर अब यह वाले पार्ट
समझते हैं। लेकिन वहीं पर
इसके अपोजिट क्या है? जो आपका कंप्यूटर
है, आपका कंप्यूटर पूरा एक शहर की तरह है।
ठीक है? शहर, एक गांव या कोई एक शहर। ठीक
है? समझ गए? एक शहर एक शहर की तरह है। ठीक
है? और जिसका जिसको Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम चलाता है। आपका जो पीसी है वह एक
शहर है, एक गांव है और जिसका मालिक कौन
है? Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। जिसका मालिक
कौन है? Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। एंड द
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम प्रोवाइड्स मेनी
लो लेवल फंक्शनंस थ्रू डीएलएल फाइल सच एज
कर्नल 32dl यूजर 32 डॉट डीएलएल सेल 32 डॉट
डीएलएल
और जो Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है उसके
पास बहुत सारे लो लेवल फंक्शनंस होते हैं
जो डीएलएल फाइल्स की फॉर्म में पैक रहते
हैं। जो गांव जो शहर है जो गांव है जिसका
मालिक Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है। तो
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के पास ऐसे बहुत
सारे पावरफुल लो लेवल फंक्शनंस होते हैं
जो डीएलएल फाइल्स की फॉर्म में स्टोर रहते
हैं। जैसे कि कर्नल 32, यूजर 32, सेल 32
ऐसे बहुत सारे सेल्स जो बहुत ज्यादा ऐसे
बहुत सारे लो लेवल फंक्शनंस जो बहुत ही
ज्यादा पावरफुल होते हैं। ठीक है? जो बहुत
ही ज्यादा पावरफुल होते हैं। अब ये दो चीज
क्लियर हो गई कि वो एक बेचारा बच्चा है।
ठीक है? और Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम आपका
वो पूरा गांव वो शहर है। ठीक है? और यह
बच्चा हमेशा अपने घर में रहता है। यह
बच्चा हमेशा अपने घर में रहता है। अब सवाल
यह है कि आपसे शुरुआत करते हैं कि जा जब
आप अपने घर में रहते हो तो आप क्या करते
हो? आपको किसी गांव में जाना है या किसी
शहर में जाना है। आप लोग बताइए आपको किसी
गांव में, किसी शहर में जाना है तो आपको
घर से बाहर निकलना होगा और शहर में आपको
कुछ काम है। कोई एग्जाम देना है, वहां से
कुछ खरीदना है, शॉपिंग करनी है, सब्जी
खरीदनी है, कुछ ना कुछ तो करना होगा। तो
वह करने के लिए आप क्या करते हो? आपको इस
घर से इस शहर में जाना है। तो क्या करोगे
आप?
इसको मत देखना। एक जनरल सवाल है। एक कॉमन
सेंस का सवाल है कि अगर आपको अपने घर से
किसी शहर में जाना है तो कैसे जाओगे आप?
बताइए। आपको अपने घर से किसी शहर में जाना
है तो कैसे जाओगे? बताइए जल्दी से।
कैसे जाओगे?
जल्दी बताइए
बताओ
बस या फिर ट्रेन से ओके बस या फिर ट्रेन
से चलो
और अब बस या ट्रेन भी तो किसी चीज से देखो
बस या ट्रेन तो मीडियम है बाकी कि एक्चुअल
जाएंगे कैसे? ये
बस या ट्रेन कोई ना कोई रास्ता यूज़
करेंगे। ट्रेन पटरी से जाएगी और बस किसी
रोड से जाएगी। तो सेम चीज है। सेम चीज है।
अगर मुझे
वीबीए
सेम चीज क्या है? कि अगर मुझे
क्या करना है? इस घर से
इस शहर में जाना है तो मैं किसका यूज़
करूंगा? ब्रिज का यूज़ करूंगा। बीच में एक
ब्रिज का यूज़ करूंगा। उस ब्रिज का नाम
क्या है? Windows एपीआई। उस ब्रिज का नाम
क्या है? Windows एपीआई। इसके यहां पर जो
रोड है, जो ब्रिज है मतलब हम खुद अगर मैं
अपने कहीं पर रह रहा हूं। मुझे शहर जाना
है तो मैं वाया रोड किसी गाड़ी से, किसी
बस से जाऊंगा। सेम वे अगर वीबीए को इस
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के साथ इंटैक्ट
करना है तो उसको भी एक रोड के थ्रू जाना
पड़ेगा। एक रास्ते के थ्रू जाना पड़ेगा।
वो रास्ता कौन सा है? Windows एपीआई। तो
व्हेन वीबीए नीड्स टू वर्क आउटसाइड द ऑफिस
एनवायरमेंट एंड इंटक्ट डायरेक्टली विद
Windows इट यूजज़ द Windows एपीआई। एपीआई
क्या होता है? एप्लीकेशन प्रोग्रामिंग
इंटरफ़ेस। एप्लीकेशन प्रोग्रामिंग इंटरफ़ेस।
मतलब अगर वीबीए को माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस की
चार दीवारी से बाहर निकलकर
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से डायरेक्ट कोई
काम करवाना है। अगर वीबीए को Microsoft
Office की चार दीवाई से बाहर निकलकर
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से डायरेक्ट कोई
काम करवाना है तो वो वो काम कैसे करवाता
है? वह काम करवाता है Windows एपीआई की
हेल्प से। वह काम करवाने के लिए क्या करता
है? Windows एपीआई की क्या करता है? यूज
करता है। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
तो फॉर एग्जांपल एक एग्जांपल लेते हैं। एक
रियल एग्जांपल लेते हैं। अभी सबसे पहले
प्रॉब्लम की बात करते हैं। आपने क्या
किया?
अपने टीममेट्स के लिए, अपने कलीग के लिए,
अपने सीनियर्स के लिए, अपने मैनेजर्स के
लिए, सुपरवाइजर्स के लिए क्या किया? काम
आसान बनाने के लिए आपने क्या किया? एक्शन
में एक बहुत ही शानदार इंटरेक्टिव फाइनेंस
मैनेजमेंट डैशबोर्ड बनाया। आपने बहुत ही
शानदार इंटरेक्टिव फाइनेंस मैनेजमेंट
बोर्ड बनाया। डैशबोर्ड बनाया और आपने यह
जो डैशबोर्ड बनाया ना, यह आपने अपने लार्ज
अपने 4K मॉनिटर पर बनाया था। जब आप यह
डैशबोर्ड डेवलप कर रहे थे, जब एक्सेल में
आप यह डैशबोर्ड बना रहे थे, तब आप यूज कर
रहे थे एक 4K मॉनिटर जिस जिसकी काफी लार्ज
स्क्रीन थी। ठीक है? लेकिन जब आपने उसको
यूज करने के लिए अपने कलीग, अपने मैनेजर,
अपने सुपीरियर्स को शेयर किया कि मैंने यह
चीज बनाई है सबका काम आसान करने के लिए तो
प्लीज आप लोग इसको यूज़ कर सकते हो। जैसे
ही आपने उसको शेयर किया और जब आपका जो
क्लाइंट है आपके जो कलीग है या आपका जो
मैनेजर है वह अपने क्या करता है किसी
13 इंच लैपटॉप में क्या करता है उसको यूज
करता है 13 इंच जो लैपटॉप है उसमें उसको
क्या करता है यूज करता है ओपन करता है
जैसे उसको ओपन करता है तो उसका जो
डैशबोर्ड यूआई है वह कट हो जाता है उसमें
स्क्रॉल बार आ जाते हैं और कहने का मतलब
जो यूआई है वह पूरी तरह से खराब हो जाता
है। भद्दा लगता है। अच्छा नहीं लगता। ऐसा
क्यों? क्योंकि बिकॉज़ स्टैंडर्ड वीबीए डज़
नॉट हैव एनी बिल्ड इन फीचर्स टू आस्क
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम फॉर द एक्चुअल
स्क्रीन, विड्थ एंड हाइट। मतलब स्टैंडर्ड
वीबीए के पास ऐसा कोई भी बिल्ड इन फीचर्स
नहीं है जो Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से
जाकर यह पूछ सके कि आपके स्क्रीन की विड्थ
और हाइट क्या है? आई एम रिपीटिंग अगेन कि
स्टैंडर्ड वीबीए के पास ऐसा कोई भी बिल्ट
इन फीचर्स नहीं है जो Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम से जाकर स्क्रीन की एक्चुअल विड्थ
और हाइट पूछ सके। अंडरस्टुड? विड्थ और
हाइट पूछ सके। समझ में आया यह चीज?
यह है प्रॉब्लम। अब इसका सॉल्यूशन क्या
है?
इसका सशन है कि आपने क्या किया? Windows
एपीआई का यूज किया। आपने Windows एपीआई का
यूज किया। किस में? आपके वीबीए कोड में।
आपने अपने वीबीए कोड में Windows एपीआई को
कॉल किया। और Windows एपीआई कॉल करने के
बाद जैसे ही आपने वर्क बुक ओपन किया तो
आपकी जो वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट है वो
ऑटोमेटिकली Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से
पूछती है कि यूजर का स्क्रीन रेोल्यूशन
क्या है और जो Windows एपीआई है आपको
स्क्रीन रेजोल्यूशन रिटर्न करती है या उस
स्क्रिप्ट को स्क्रीन रेोल्यूशन रिटर्न
करती है। जैसे ही उसको स्क्रीन रेजोल्यूशन
मिलता है तो वो जो वीबीए है तुरंत क्या
करता है जो डैशबोर्ड का साइज है उसका जो
फोंट की स्केलिंग है उसको स्क्रीन साइज के
हिसाब से एडजस्ट कर देता है। उसको स्क्रीन
साइज के हिसाब से एडजस्ट कर देता है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? पॉइंट नंबर टू कि
वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से आप Windows
एपीआई का के साथ इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हो।
पॉइंट नंबर टू क्लियर है।
मोहित इस पे बाद में बात करेंगे। ओके।
क्योंकि अभी क्लास के बीच में सवाल आपका
सही नहीं है।
पॉइंट नंबर टू सबको क्लियर है? देयर ओनली
थ्री पर्सन जिनको क्लियर है। ओके। नूड को
भी क्लियर है। उसके बाद इनको भी क्लियर
है। सेकंड मोहित को क्लियर है। अनोनिमस को
भी क्लियर है। सेकंड
8197 को भी क्लियर है।
बाकी 1 2 3 4 5 ओनली पांच लोगों को क्लियर
है।
छह ओके छह ओनली सिक्स ओनली सिक्स
ओनली सिक्स
बाकी लोग बाकी लोग
बाकी लोग जल्दी बताओ जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी
जल्दी चलिए फिर पॉइंट नंबर थ्री पे आते
हैं। अगर छह लोगों को समझ में आया तो इसका
मतलब या तो यह है कि बाकी लोग
लोगों ने क्या किया है? कुछ काम कर रहे
हैं। इयरफोन पे साइड में मोबाइल पे चलाया
हुआ है कि सुन लेते हैं। दे आर वेरी बिजी।
दूसरा या फिर उन्होंने ऑन करके कहीं चले
गए हैं या फिर उनको समझ में नहीं आया।
पता नहीं मुझे समझ में नहीं आया मोहित आप
क्या बोल रहे हो।
चलिए फिर पॉइंट नंबर थ्री पे आ जाते हैं।
पॉइंट नंबर थ्री क्या था कि मैंने आपको
क्या बोला था कि वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट की
हेल्प से आप क्या कर सकते हो? कस्टम यूजर
डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस क्रिएट कर सकते हो।
कस्टम यूजर डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस क्रिएट कर
सकते हो। सी सबने यहां पर एक्सेल यूज किया
है। सब ने यहां पर कभी ना कभी एक्सेल यूज़
किया है।
ओके। तो अगर आप लोगों ने एक्सेल यूज किया
होगा तो एक्सेल में बहुत सारे बिल्ट इन
फार्मूलाज होते हैं। बहुत सारे बिल्ट इन
फार्मूलाज़ होते हैं। जैसे आपका सम जैसे
एवरेज जैसे VLOOKUP ठीक है? ऐसे बहुत सारे
बिल्ट इन फार्मूलाज़ होते हैं। लेकिन इफ यू
नीड टू परफॉर्म ए कॉम्प्लेक्स कैलकुलेशन
और बिजनेस लॉजिक दैट कैन नॉट बी हैंडल्ड
प्रॉपर्ली विद स्टैंडर्ड फार्मूलाज़। वीबीए
अलाउज यू टू क्रिएट योर ओन कस्टम एक्सेल
फार्मूलाज़। इसका मतलब क्या है? इसका मतलब
यह है। लेकिन फिर भी अगर आपके पास कोई ऐसी
कॉम्प्लेक्स लॉजिक या कैलकुलेशन है जो इन
स्टैंडर्ड फार्मूलाज़ से नहीं परफॉर्म हो
सकती। तो आप वीबीए का यूज़ करके अपने कस्टम
एक्सेल फार्मूलाज़ भी बना सकते हो। और जो
कस्टम एक्सेल फार्मूलाज़ आप बनाओगे उसी को
हम बोलते हैं यूजर डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस
यूडीएफ उसी को हम बोलते हैं यूजर डिफाइंड
फंक्शनंस मतलब क्या किया अगर आप वीबीए की
हेल्प से अपना खुद का कोई फार्मूला बना
रहे हो एक्सेल में या किसी वर्ड में तो
फिर क्या है उसको हम बोलेंगे यूजर डिफाइंड
फंक्शन यूडीएफ अंडरस्टुड पॉइंट नंबर थ्री
कि वीबी की हेल्प से आप अपने कस्टम यूजर
डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस भी बना सकते हो, क्रिएट
कर सकते हो। पॉइंट नंबर थ्री किस-किस को
क्लियर है यहां पर?
पॉइंट नंबर थ्री किस-किस को क्लियर है?
ओके। ओनली वन
न्यूड को सबसे पहले क्लियर है। बाकी
अनोनिमस मोहित
टेक्स टेक्नो स्पार्क
बताइए बताइए।
चलिए तो अभी आते हैं पॉइंट नंबर चार पर।
पॉइंट नंबर चार है आपका मैनपुलेटिंग एंड
कस्टमाइजिंग द होस्ट एप्लीकेशन। मैंने
आपको पॉइंट नंबर चार में क्या बताया था?
मैंने आपको बताया था कि वीबीएस
स्क्रिप्टिंग की हेल्प से या वीबीएस
स्क्रिप्टिंग के जरिए आप होस्ट एप्लीकेशन
की यूआई को मैनपुलेट और कस्टमाइज कर सकते
हो। इसका क्या मतलब होता है? इसका मतलब
होता है कि जो Microsoft Office है उसके
अंदर जो एक्सेल है जो वर्ड है आप उसके लुक
फील और यूजर इंटरेक्शन फीचर को अपने हिसाब
से बदल और कस्टमाइज कर सकते हो। ऐड या
सबट्रैक्ट कर सकते हो। ठीक है? ऐड या
सबट्रैक्ट कर सकते हो। कैसे? फॉर एग्जांपल
आप क्या कर सकते हो? कोई आपने देखा होगा
बहुत सारे डैशबोर्ड यूआई बहुत सारी कंपनीज
में अगर काम होता है या कभी एक्सेल में
आपने देखे होंगे कि बहुत सारी कैलकुलेशन
होती है और सामने एक डैशबोर्ड सा आता है।
ठीक है? सामने डैशबोर्ड सा आता है। तो वो
क्या है? देखो डैशबोर्ड में आपने क्या
किया? कुछ फॉर्म फॉर्म फिल फॉर्म टाइप का
दिखता है। उस फॉर्म में आप डाटा डालते हो।
सब ओके कर देते हो। सबमिट कर देते हो और
आपका डाटा ऐड हो जाता है। तो क्या कर सकते
हैं? आप खुद के कस्टम फॉर्म्स बना सकते
हो। या फिर जो एक्सेल है एक्सेल में एक
ऊपर लाइन होती है जहां पर फाइल, मेनू,
इंसर्ट, पेज लेआउट, फार्मूलाज़ वो रिबन
होता है। वहां पर भी क्या कर सकते हो?
अपना खुद का कस्टम रिबन क्या कर सकते हो?
ऐड कर सकते हो, डिज़ कर सकते हो। या फिर आप
क्या कर सकते हो? जो उसके साइड में क्या
है? आपके अ चेक बॉक्स ऐड कर सकते हो। कोई
कस्टम बटन ऐड कर सकते हो, कोई टेक्स्ट
बॉक्स ऐड कर सकते हो। ऐसी बहुत सारी चीजें
आप क्या कर सकते हो? कस्टमाइज कर सकते हो
उस पर्टिकुलर एप्लीकेशन के अंदर। फॉर
एग्जांपल एक एग्जांपल लेते हैं। फॉर
एग्जांपल कि आप नहीं चाहते कि आपका जो
यूजर है वो डायरेक्टली एक्सेल शीट में रो
डाटा टाइप करें। आप नहीं चाहते कि आपका जो
यूजर है या जो आपका
आपके साथ काम करने वाला जो बड़ी है आप
नहीं चाहते आप एक एडमिन है या आप सीनियर
हैं या आप का जो जूनियर है कलीग आया है आप
नहीं चाहते कि वो डायरेक्टली उस एक्सेल
शीट में डाटा ऐड करें क्योंकि क्योंकि वह
गलती कर सकता है हो और पता हो सकता है कि
उसके एक गलत डाटा से मिसकैलकुलेशन हो गया
तो आप क्या कर सकते हो इसके लिए आप वीबीएस
स्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से एक कस्टम फॉर्म बना
सकते हो। उसको पॉपअप करवा सकते हो। और
जैसे ही वह आपका क्लिकग है, जैसे ही वह
यूजर उसमें डिटेल फिल करेगा और सबमिट बटन
पर क्लिक करेगा, तो वह सारा का सारा डेट
डाटा ऑटोमेटिकली
सही फॉर्मेट में सही जगह पर सही शीट के
अंदर ऑटोमेटिकली अरेंज हो जाएगा। तो, यह
सारे काम आप क्या कर सकते हो? वीबीए
स्क्रिप्टिंग की हेल्प से कर सकते हो। आई
एम रिपीटिंग कि अगर आप चाहते हो कि आपका
जो दोस्त है या आप चाहते हो कि किसी कंपनी
में काम करते हो कि आपने उसको एक डैशबोर्ड
दे दिया। आपको एक पॉपअप फॉर्म दिया कि भाई
एक काम करो आप यह फॉर्म है। इस फॉर्म में
डाटा फिल करो और उस बटन को दबा दो। आपका
डाटा ऐड हो जाएगा। आप डायरेक्टली उसको
एक्सेल शीट का एक्सेस नहीं देना चाहते कि
जिसके अंदर वो ऐड हो रहा है उस पर्टिकुलर
एक्स शीट के अंदर क्योंकि हो सकता है किसी
गलत कॉलम में किसी गलत जगह पर वो डेटा
एंट्री कर दे इसीलिए आपने क्या किया
वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से एक फॉर्म
डिजाइन करवाया उस फॉर्म में एक बटन ऐड
किया वो पॉप अप करेगा उसमें यूजर डिटेल
भरेगा उसको ओके दबाएगा ओके दबाने के बाद
क्या हुआ वो डाटा सही फॉर्मेट में सही जगह
पर सही शीट में ऑटोमेटिकली अरेंज और ऐड हो
जाएगा यह है पॉइंट नंबर नंबर फोर यह है
पॉइंट नंबर फोर। तो
इसलिए जैसा कि मैंने आपको बताया कि वीबीएस
स्क्रिप्टिंग के जरिए आप यह चार काम कर
सकते हो। सबसे पहला रिपीिटेटिव मैनुअल
टास्क को ऑटोमेट कर सकते हो। Windows
एपीआई के साथ इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हो। पॉइंट
नंबर थ्री आप कस्टम यूजर डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस
क्रिएट कर सकते हो। थर्ड आप क्या कर सकते
हो? जो होस्ट एप्लीकेशन है एक्सेल या आपका
कौन सा है माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड है उसके जो
यूआई को आप मैनपुलेट और कस्टमाइज कर सकते
हो तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर है
कौन सा नाम आपको समझ में नहीं आया मोहित
जरा टाइप करना यूजर डिफाइंड
फंक्शन
यूडीएफ
यूडीएफ समझ में नहीं आया।
यूडीएफ समझ में नहीं आया। बताओ
देखो यूजर डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस क्या होता है
कि अगर आपने मोहित कभी एक्सेल यूज़ किया
होगा एक्सेल में बहुत सारे फार्मूलाज़ होते
हैं जिसमें आप क्या कर सकते हो दो नंबर्स
को ऐड कर सकते हो अह उसको सब्ट्रैक्ट कर
सकते हो उसका सम निकाल सकते हो उनकी
कैलकुलेशन कर सकते हो तो इसके अलावा क्या
है कि एक्सेल के अंदर जो पहले से
प्रीडफाइंड फार्मूलाज़ हैं या प्रीडफाइंड
आपके जो कैलकुलेशंस के लिए जो फंक्शनंस
दिए हुए हैं जिनको आप यूज़ करते हो अगर
आपका लॉजिक फिल आपके आपको अपना काम करने
के लिए अगर आपका जो लॉजिक है और जो आपकी
कैलकुलेशन है वो इतनी कॉम्प्लेक्स है कि
उन फ़ूलाज़ से जो इनबिल्ट फ़ूलाज़ हैं जो बाय
डिफ़ॉल्ट फ़ूलाज़ एक्सेल के अंदर प्रेजेंट है
उनसे फुल फुलफिल नहीं हो रही। आपको उसके
लिए खुद का कोई फार्मूला बनाना पड़ेगा।
खुद के लॉजिक लगाने पड़ेंगे। तो क्या करते
हो आप? वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से खुद
का एक फार्मूला
डिजाइन करते हो, डिफाइन करते हो। उसी को
हम बोलते हैं कस्टम डिफाइंड कस्टम डिफाइंड
फंक्शनंस। यू डीएफ कस्टम यूजर डिफाइंड।
आपने क्या किया? खुद से उसको बनाया है ना
कि बिल्ट इन फार्मूला। अंडरस्टुड?
अभी मोहित आपको समझ में आ गया?
चलिए
अगर आपको समझ में आ गया तो आगे बढ़ते हैं।
आपको अगर समझ में आ गया तो आगे बढ़ते हैं।
बढ़े आगे।
नेक्स्ट
पॉइंट नंबर थ्री
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड एंड एक्सेल अलव यूजर्स
टू एंबेड वीबीए मैस इन डॉक्यूमेंट्स एंड
स्प्रेडशीट्स फॉर द ऑटोमेशन ऑफ मैनुअल
टास्क एंड मैनेजमेंट ऑफ डायनेमिक डाटा एंड
फॉर द लिंकिंग ऑफ डॉक्यूमेंट्स। इसका मतलब
क्या है? इसका मतलब यह है कि जो Microsoft
Word है और Excel ने यूजर को जो Microsoft
Word और Excel है वह यूजर को अलव करता है
कि वह अपने डॉक्यूमेंट्स और स्प्रेडशीट्स
के अंदर वीबीए कोड को एंबेड कर सकता है।
मतलब कि जो Microsoft Office Word है जो
Excel है उसके अंदर यूजर वीबीए कोड को
क्या कर सकता है? एंबेड कर सकता है या
डिजाइन करके उसके अंदर ऐड कर सकता है।
उसके उसके अंदर एंबेड कर सकता है। यह
यूज़र्स को अलऊ किया है किसने? Microsoft
Office Office ने। ठीक है? अपने सूट के
अंदर। क्यों अलऊ किया है? क्योंकि
ताकि जो यूज़र्स हैं वो डायनेमिक डेटा
मैनेजमेंट और डॉक्यूमेंट्स लिंकिंग
परफॉर्म कर सकें। जिससे यूज़र्स डायनेमिक
डाटा मैनेजमेंट और डॉक्यूमेंट लिंकिंग
परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? किस पर्पस
के लिए? डायनेमिक डाटा लिंकिंग एंड
डायनेमिक डाटा मैनेजमेंट एंड डॉक्यूमेंट
लिंकिंग। इसीलिए यूजर ने क्या किया है?
इसीलिए माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ने यूज़र्स को यह
टास्क परफॉर्म करने के लिए अलऊ किया हुआ
है कि यूज़र्स खुद से माइक्रो कोड एंबेड कर
सकता है किसी भी माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड और
एक्सेल शीट के अंदर उसका कारण क्या है?
डायनेमिक डेटा मैनेजमेंट और लिंकिंग ऑफ
डॉक्यूमेंट्स। अब आप लोगों को यह दोनों
टर्म नहीं पता होंगे कि डायनेमिक डाटा
मैनेजमेंट और डॉक्यूमेंट लिंकिंग क्या
होता है। ठीक है? चलिए फिर समझते हैं कि
यहां पर जो डायनेमिक डेटा मैनेजमेंट है और
जो डॉक्यूमेंट लिंकिंग है उससे हमारा क्या
मतलब है? उससे हमारा क्या मतलब है? चलिए
फिर डायनेमिक डाटा मैनेजमेंट की बात करते
हैं। देखिए सबसे पहले बात करते हैं।
स्टैटिक डाटा की इन नॉर्मल एक्सेल शीट
डाटा इज स्टैटिक व्हाटएवर यू टाइप स्टेज
देयर अंटिल यू मैनुअली चेंज इट मतलब
नॉर्मल एक्सेल शीट में डेटा क्या होता है
आपका स्टैटिक रहता है मतलब जो आपने टाइप
कर दिया वो वहीं पर पड़ा रहेगा और जब तक
पड़ा रहेगा जब तक आप उसको खुद से चेंज
नहीं करते लेकिन वहीं पर डायनेमिक डेटा
मैनेजमेंट में क्या होता है डायनेमिक डेटा
मैनेज मैनेजमेंट मींस डेटा ऑटोमेटिकली
कैलकुलेट्स अपडेट एंड वैलिडेट इटसेल्फ
बेस्ड ऑन रियल टाइम कंडीशंस विदाउट मैनुअल
हार्ड वर्क। लेकिन वहीं पर जो डायनेमिक
डेटा मैनेजमेंट है उसका मतलब है डेटा अपने
आप रियल टाइम कंडीशन के हिसाब से कैलकुलेट
अपडेट और वैलिडेट होता है बिना किसी
मैनुअल हार्ड वर्क के। ठीक है? तो एक्सेल
में दो टाइप का डाटा होता है। एक तो
स्टैटिक डाटा जो आपने एक बार टाइप कर दिया
वह एज इट इज पढ़ा है। जब उसको आप चेंज
करोगे तब वो चेंज होगा। दूसरा कौन सा होता
है आपका? डायनेमिक डेटा मैनेजमेंट।
डायनेमिक डाटा क्या होता है कि आपने ऐसे
कैलकुलेशंस उसके कंडीशंस लगाई हुई हैं।
उसके अंदर वीबीए मैक की हेल्प से या वीबीए
की हेल्प से वह ऑटोमेटिकली क्या होता है?
अपडेट होता रहता है। उस डाटा को कैलकुलेट
करता रहता है और वैलिडेट करता रहता है
रियल टाइम में बिना किसी ह्यूमन इंटरेक्शन
के बिना बिना मैनुअल हार्ड वर्क के वो
ऑटोमेटिकली करता रहता है। जैसे आपने क्या
किया? कोई एक नई वैल्यू ऐड की और जैसे
एक्सेल शीट को ऑन किया तो ऑटोमेटिकली
कैलकुलेट करके उसका क्या हो जाएगा? नई
वैल्यू या नया डाटा अपडेट हो जाएगा। तो ये
क्या है आपका? डायनेमिक डेटा मैनेजमेंट।
चलिए फिर मैं आपको एक रियल वर्ल्ड
एग्जांपल से समझाता हूं। सबसे पहले हम बात
करते हैं स्टैटिक की नॉर्मल तरीके की।
नॉर्मल तरीके में क्या करते हैं? आप क्या
करते हो? फॉर एग्जांपल आप क्या करते हो?
कोई अकाउंट बैलेंस शीट बना रहे हो। ठीक
है? अकाउंट बैलेंस शीट बना रहे हो किसके
अंदर? एक्सेल शीट के अंदर। तो आप क्या
करते हो? सबसे पहले बेस लाइन प्राइस को
टाइप करते हो। बेस लाइन प्राइस टाइप करने
के बाद आप टैक्स कैलकुलेशन के लिए
कैलकुलेटर निकालते हैं। कैलकुलेटर निकालने
के बाद उसके ऊपर टैक्स कैलकुलेट करते हो।
टैक्स कैलकुलेट करने के बाद जो फाइनल टोटल
अमाउंट आता है उस टोटल अमाउंट को आप
मैनुअली टाइप करते हो उस एक्सेल शीट के
अंदर। यह आपका स्टैटिक वे है। यह आपका
स्टैटिक तरीका है। दूसरा डायनेमिक तरीका
क्या होगा? डायनेमिक तरीका होगा आपका।
आपने क्या किया? एक
सिर्फ आपने एक फॉर्म बनाया हुआ है। फॉर्म
में आपने क्या किया कि सेलेक्ट करना है
रीजन को। आपको उस पर्टिकुलर कंट्री का
रीजन सेलेक्ट करना है। उस पर्टिकुलर
कंट्री को सेलेक्ट करना है। जैसे यूएसए
है, इंडिया है। जैसे आप उसको सेलेक्ट करते
हो। सेलेक्ट करते ही जो वीबीए कोड है
बैकग्राउंड में ऑटोमेटिकली डिटेक्ट करेगा
कि टारगेट करेंसी क्या होनी चाहिए? आपने
यूएसए सेलेक्ट किया डॉलर होने चाहिए।
इंडिया सेलेक्ट किया रुपए होने चाहिए।
लोकल टैक्स कितना परसेंटेज लगेगा? उस
पर्टिकुलर अमाउंट पर जो टैक्स है वो कितना
लगेगा? इंडिया में 18% जीएसटी यूएसए में
कुछ भी हो सकता है। उसी हिसाब से फिर क्या
इस पर डिस्काउंट अप्लाई होगा या नहीं
होगा? ऑटोमेटिकली डिस्काउंट अप्लाई होगा
या नहीं होगा? उसके बाद यह सारी कैलकुलेशन
करने के बाद वो ऑटोमेटिकली आपकी एक्सेल
शीट में लाइव अपडेट हो जाएगी। तो, यह है
आपका डायनेमिक डेटा मैनेजमेंट। यह आपका
डायनेमिक डेटा मैनेजमेंट आ गया। अब आ गया
उसकी बात करते हैं हम।
डॉक्यूमेंट लिंकिंग की डॉक्यूमेंट लिंकिंग
का मतलब क्या होता है कि जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
ऑफिस के अंदर जो अलग-अलग एप्लीकेशनेशंस है
जैसे कि आपकी एक्सेल है आपका वर्ड है,
पावर पॉइंट है, आउटलुक है, उन सबको आपस
में क्या करना? चेंज करना या एक नेटवर्क
की तरह उनको जोड़ना।
डॉक्यूमेंट लिंकिंग का मतलब क्या है?
Microsoft Office सूट के अंदर जितने भी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस हैं जैसे कि वर्ड हो गया,
पीपी पावर पावर पॉइंट हो गया, एक्सेल हो
गया या आपका आउटलुक हुआ उन सबको क्या
करना? आपस में एक चेन की तरह जोड़ना नहीं
समझ में आया होगा आपको। मैं समझाता हूं।
फॉर एग्जांपल एक नॉर्मल यूजर क्या करता
है? नॉर्मल यूजर फॉर एग्जांपल क्या करता
है? सबसे पहले वो क्या करता है? एक्सेल से
डाटा कॉपी करता है। उसके बाद उसको वर्ड
ओपन करता है और वर्ड के अंदर पेस्ट करता
है। और वर्ड में पेस्ट करने के बाद वो
क्या करता है? उसके ऊपर अगर कोई
प्रेजेंटेशन बनाना तो प्रेजेंटेशन बनाता
है। देन उस डेटा को फिर आउटलुक ओपन करके
अटैच करता है। मतलब आपने एक्सेल शीट मिली।
Excel शीट को ओपन किया। वहां से डेटा को
कॉपी किया। फिर वर्ड को ओपन किया। वहां पर
पेस्ट किया। फिर उसकी प्रेजेंटेशन रेडी
की। फिर उसके बाद क्या किया? उसकी एक
अटैचमेंट बनाई। अटैचमेंट बनाकर आउटलुक के
थ्रू आपने क्या किया? उसको भेज दिया।
आउटलुक के थ्रू आपने भेज दिया। यह सारा
काम कैसे किया आपने? नॉर्मल किया। वहीं पर
एक प्रोफेशनल जो आपका बोल सकते हैं एक
प्रोफेशनल बंदा होगा वो क्या करेगा? वो
डॉक्यूमेंट लिंकिंग के जरिए क्या करेगा?
वीबीआई की यूज़ करेगा। और वीबीए की हेल्प
से यह सारा काम बैकग्राउंड में ऑटोमेटिकली
एक सिंगल बटन से कर देगा। जैसा मैंने
बताया था ना कि उस एग्जांपल में कि जस्ट
आपने एक बटन पर क्लिक किया। उसने सारे
डाटा को कैलकुलेट किया। कैलकुलेट करके एक
पीडीएफ जनरेट किया। पीडीएफ जनरेट करने के
बाद ऑटोमेटिकली मेल आउट कर दिया मैनेजमेंट
को। ऑटोमेटिकली मेल आउट कर दिया मैनेजमेंट
को। अगर रियल वर्ल्ड एग्जांपल समझाता हूं।
फॉर एग्जांपल एन एक्सेल फाइल कंटेन ए
लिस्ट ऑफ 100 क्लाइंट्स एंड देयर पेंडिंग
बिल डाटा। फॉर एग्जांपल आपकी एक्सेल शीट
में 100 क्लाइंट्स की लिस्ट है और उनके
पेंडिंग बिल्स का डाटा है। और आपने क्या
किया? आपने अपने जो वीबीए है वीबीए
स्क्रिप्टिंग्स में डिजाइन किया हुआ है कि
जैसे ही आप सिंगल बटन प्रेस करोगे। जैसे
ही आप सिंगल बटन प्रेस करोगे बटन प्रेस
करते ही जो वीबीए क्या करता है? वीबीए
ऑटोमेटिकली एक्सेल से उस डाटा को रीड करता
है। डाटा को रीड करके फिर वर्ड को ओपन
करता है बैकग्राउंड में और उसके अंदर क्या
करता है? उस पर्टिकुलर हर एक क्लाइंट का
इनवॉइस या नोट जनरेट करता है। इनवॉइस और
नोट जनरेट करने के बाद उसको पीडीएफ में
कन्वर्ट करता है। पीडीएफ में कन्वर्ट करने
के बाद जो पर्टिकुलर क्लाइंट है उसको क्या
कर देता है? मेल आउट कर देता है। उसको
आउटलुक के थ्रू मेल भेज देता है। जस्ट एक
सिंगल क्लिक से। जस्ट एक सिंगल क्लिक से
जस्ट एक सिंगल क्लिक से समझ में आया कि
डॉक्यूमेंट लिंकिंग और डायनेमिक डाटा
दोनों का क्या मतलब है इसके अंदर तो यह
सारा काम आपका वीबीए ऑटोमेटिकली कर सकता
है। तो सोच के देखिए कि वीबीए कब से है?
Microsoft ऑफिस में कब से है? क्योंकि यह
सारी चीजें हम वेबसाइट पर भी करते हैं।
लेकिन अगर आप पर्टिकुलर एक आइसोलेटेड
एनवायरमेंट में कर रहे हो डेट डेली ऐसे
डेटा के साथ हैंडल कर रहे हो जहां पर आपको
इंटरनेट का कोई काम ही नहीं है। डेली आपको
एक्सेल वर्ड और आउटलुक का ही यूज़ करना
है। तो आप वीबीए की हेल्प से सारा काम कर
सकते हो। कोई वेबसाइट बनाने की जरूरत नहीं
है कि वेबसाइट पे जाके आप क्या करोगे?
डाटा वो करोगे कि उसके लिए कोई वेब की
रिक्वायरमेंट है। नहीं वीबी सारे वो काम
करती है जैसे आप रियल टाइम में किसी
वेबसाइट पे कर सकते हो।
मैं समझा नहीं आप क्या कहने की कोशिश कर
रहे हो। तो सबको यहां तक समझ में आ गया।
मैं आपके फंडामेंटल क्लियर कर रहा हूं। यह
मैं आपको कुछ भी परफॉर्म नहीं करने वाला।
हम जस्ट टेस्टिंग पर्पस से जो हमें करना
है, अगर मुझे अपने पेलोड को छुपाना है,
किसी पेड को ड्रॉप करना है, इसकी हेल्प से
वह सारी चीज मैं प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे।
इससे ज्यादा डीप में देखो मेरा काम है
आपको फंडामेंटल क्लियर करवाना। यह चीज
देखो ना तो मैं कोई आपको फाइनेंस
डिपार्टमेंट की एक्सेल शीट बनाना सिखा रहा
ना कोई यह सीए की तैयारी चल रही। यह जस्ट
यह है कि आप पेन टेस्टिंग में आपको पता
होना चाहिए कि वीबीए क्या है? वीबीए
क्या-क्या काम करती है।
हां ये देखो बेसिक है। एक-एक चीज डिटेल
में सीखने का मतलब यह है कि हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? इसके प्रैक्टिकल्स परफॉर्म
करेंगे एज ए पेंटेस्टर। डोंट वरी। बिल्कुल
स्टार्टिंग में सारी चीज जो आपको पता होने
चाहिए बेसिक लेवल पे आई विल एक्सप्लेन।
तो नेक्स्ट
बात करते हैं वीबीए फीचर्स की। नेक्स्ट
बात करते हैं हम इनके फीचर्स की बात करते
हैं। चलिए फिर फीचर्स की बात करते हैं। तो
लेट्स स्टार्ट वन बाय वन। पर्पज से
स्टार्ट करते हैं। सबसे पहले हम स्टार्ट
करते हैं पर्पज से। वीबीए अलव यूज़र्स टू
राइट प्रोग्राम्स टू ऑटोमेट रिपीिटेटिव
टास्क, परफॉर्म कैलकुलेशन, मैनपुलेट डेटा,
क्रिएट कस्टम फॉर्म्स एंड इंटैक्ट विद अदर
एप्लीकेशनेशंस। इसका मतलब क्या है कि
वीबीए का पर्पस क्या है? वीबीए का पर्पस
है कॉम्प्लेक्स कैलकुलेशन परफॉर्म करना,
डाटा मैनपुलेट करना, कस्टम यूजर फॉर्म
बनाना और मल्टीपल ऑफिससेस एप्लीकेशन के
बीच क्या करना? कम्युनिकेशन सेट करना।
जैसे किसके बीच में? एक्सेल, वर्ड, पावर
पॉइंट, आउटलुक इनके बीच में क्या करना?
कम्युनिकेशन एस्टैब्लिश करना।
अब पॉइंट नंबर टू इंटीग्रेशन की बात करते
हैं हम। वीबीए इज टाइटली इंटीग्रेटेड इनू
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस एप्लीकेशन।
जो वीबीए है वह Microsoft Office के साथ
डीपली इंटीग्रेटेड होती है। मींस इट
प्रोवाइडिंग एक्सेस टू ए रिच सेट ऑफ
ऑब्जेक्ट्स, प्रॉपर्टीज, मेथड्स, इवेंट्स
दैट अलाउ फॉर एक्सटेंसिव कस्टमाइजेशन एंड
ऑटोमेशन।
मतलब
इसके पास Microsoft Office के अंदर हर एक
ऑब्जेक्ट, प्रॉपर्टीज, मेथड्स, इवेंट्स उन
सबका प्रॉपर एक्सेस होता है आपके
कस्टमाइजेशन और ऑटोमेशन पर्पस के लिए।
मतलब जो वीबीए है, वह Microsoft Office के
साथ डीपली इंटीग्रेटेड होती है। और इसके
पास Microsoft Office के अंदर जितने भी
ऑब्जेक्ट्स हैं, जितने भी प्रॉपर्टीज हैं,
जो भी मेथड्स हैं, जो भी इवेंट्स हैं,
उनका क्या कह सकते? उनका एक प्रॉपर एक्सेस
होता है आपके कस्टमाइजेशन और ऑटोमेशन के
लिए। अब सिंटेक्स की बात करें। वीबीएस
सिंटेक्स इज सिमिलर टू अदर प्रोग्रामिंग
लैंग्वेज लाइक विजुअल बेसिक एंड बेसिक। इट
इज ए कॉम्बिनेशन ऑफ कीवर्ड ऑपरेटर्स,
वेरिएबल्स एंड कंट्रोल स्ट्रक्चर्स टू
क्रिएट एग्जीक्यूटेबल कोड। मतलब इसका जो
सिंटेक्स है वह स्टैंडर्ड विजुअल बेसिक या
किसी भी बेसिक प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज जैसा
ही है। यह भी क्या करता है? कीवर्ड्स का
यूज करता है, ऑपरेटर्स का यूज करता है,
वेरिएबल्स का यूज करता है। या जो कंट्रोल
स्ट्रक्चर्स है ना इफ, एल्स, व्हेन, लूप
इन सबका यह भी यूज़ करता है अपनी
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज के अंदर। अब
डेवलपमेंट एनवायरमेंट की बात करें तो ईच
ऑफिस एप्लीकेशन इंक्लूड ए बिल्ड इन वीबीए
इंटीग्रेटेड डेवलपमेंट एनवायरमेंट। वेयर
यूज़र्स कैन राइट, एडिट, डीबग और रन वीबीए
कोड। मतलब यह है कि हर एक ऑफिस एप्लीकेशन
के अंदर बिल्ड इन वीबीए आईडी ही होता है।
आईडी मतलब इंटीग्रेटेड डेवलपमेंट
एनवायरमेंट। मतलब जो भी एप्लीकेशन है चाहे
वो एक्सेल है, चाहे वर्ड है, पीपीटी है
सबके अंदर क्या रहता है? एक बिल्ड इन
वीबीए आईडी एनवायरमेंट सेट रहता है
इंटीग्रेटेड डेवलपमेंट एनवायरमेंट जिसमें
आप क्या कर सकते हो? जिसमें आप उस उस आईडी
को ओपन करके अपना कोड लिख सकते हो, एडिट
कर सकते हो, डीबग कर सकते हो और टेस्ट कर
सकते हो। डीबग कर सकते हो, टेस्ट कर सकते
हो। तो चारों पॉइंट क्लियर है आपको? पर्पज
क्या है? इंटीग्रेशन, सिंटेक्स, डेवलपमेंट
एनवायरमेंट। चारों पॉइंट आपको क्लियर है?
चारों पॉइंट आपको क्लियर है?
बिलकुल। बेसिक्स मैं सिखाऊंगा जो हमारी
पेन टेस्टिंग के लिए रिक्वायरमेंट है।
वीबीएससी हम ड्रॉपर बनाना सीखेंगे।
तो अभी नेक्स्ट पॉइंट पे आते हैं हम।
ऑब्जेक्ट्स एंड मेथड्स। ऑब्जेक्ट्स एंड
मेथड्स। वीबीए अलाउस यूजर टू वर्क विद
ऑब्जेक्ट्स दैट रिप्रेजेंट एलिमेंट्स ऑफ द
ऑफिस एप्लीकेशनेशंस। फॉर एग्जांपल
वर्कशीट, सेल्स, शेप्स एंड मैनपुलेट देम
यूजिंग मेथड्स एंड प्रॉपर्टीज। आपको नहीं
समझ में आया होगा। तो इसको समझाने के लिए
मैं आपको लेकर आता हूं इस पॉइंट पर। इसका
मतलब क्या है? वीबीए आल्सो वर्क ऑन एन
ऑब्जेक्ट ओरिएंटेड पैराडिगम। इन एक्सेल
एव्री एलिमेंट इज ट्रीटेड लाइक एन
ऑब्जेक्ट।
इसका मतलब क्या है? वीबीए भी आपके
ऑब्जेक्ट ओरिएंटेड पैराडिगम पर काम करती
है। जो वीबीए है वह भी आपकी ऑब्जेक्ट
ओरिएंटेड पैराडिगम पर काम करती है। मतलब
एक्सेल के अंदर हर एक एलिमेंट एक ऑब्जेक्ट
की तरह ट्रीट होता है। एक्सेल या वर्ड
उसके अंदर जो भी एलिमेंट है चाहे वो टैब
है, चाहे उसके अंदर बॉक्स है, उसके अंदर
सेल है, रेंज है, वर्कशीट है, हर एक चीज
को क्या किया जाता है? एक ऑब्जेक्ट की तरह
ट्रिएट किया जाता है। फॉर एग्जांपल जो
एक्सेल है एक्सेल की भी अपनी खुद की एक
हरार्की होती है। जैसे सबसे पहले
एप्लीकेशन एंटायर माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एप्लीकेशन
हरार्की में सबसे पहले आता है। हरार्की
में सबसे पहले आता है। नंबर दो पे आता है
उसका वर्कब एक्सेल की जो फाइल है। उसके
बाद आती है वर्कशीट। यह थर्ड नंबर पे आती
है। फोर्थ नंबर कौन से आते हैं आपके? रेंज
और सेल। तो हर एक एप्लीकेशन की अपनी एक
हरार्की होती है। एक ऑब्जेक्ट हरार्की
होती है। तो एक्सेल की ये ऑब्जेक्ट
हरार्की है। पहले एक्सेल एप्लीकेशन उसके
अंदर फिर वर्क बुक जो आपका एक्सेल फाइल है
जो आप सेव करते हो उसके बाद वर्कशीट उसके
बाद रेंज। नाउ एवरीथिंग यू सी इन एक्सेल
सच एज वर्कशीट सेल चार्ट टेबल और वर्क विच
वर्क बुक इज एन ऑब्जेक्ट। अब एक्सेल के
अंदर जो भी चीज आप स्क्रीन पर देखते हो
चाहे वो वर्कशीट हो, सेल हो, चार्ट हो, रो
हो, टेबल हो, वर्क बुक हो, वो सब क्या है?
ऑब्जेक्ट के अंदर आते हैं। वो सब ऑब्जेक्ट
के अंदर आते हैं। एंड टू मॉडिफाई दीज़
ऑब्जेक्ट्स, वीबीए यूजज़ देयर प्रॉपर्टीज
एंड मेथड्स। और इनको मॉडिफाई करने के लिए
वो क्या करता है? मेथड्स और प्रॉपर्टीज का
यूज़ करता है। अब मेथड्स और प्रॉपर्टीज
क्या होंगे? फिर फॉर एग्जांपल एक सेल है।
सेल के अंदर आपने क्या कर दिया? कोई कलर
फिल कर दिया। उसकी वैल्यू चेंज कर दी।
वैल्यू डिलीट कर दिया। तो ये मेथड और
प्रॉपर्टीज के अंदर आते हैं। सेल एक
ऑब्जेक्ट है। ऑब्जेक्ट के अंदर आप इसकी
शेप चेंज कर रहे हो, साइज बढ़ा रहे हो,
इसका फोंट सेलेक्ट कर रहे हो। तो वो क्या
आ गया? आपका प्रॉपर्टीज हो गया। इसके अंदर
डिलीट करना है, इंसर्ट करना है, यह करना
है। ये साइज का मेथड आ गया। यह आपका
ऑब्जेक्ट्स एंड मेथड्स। तो वीबीए भी क्या
कर क्या करती है? ऑब्जेक्ट और मेथड के
फॉर्म में ही काम करती है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है?
फंडामेंटल क्लियर हो गया सबको?
सबको फंडामेंटल क्लियर है? यह फंडामेंटल
है वीबीए मैक। हम नेक्स्ट क्लास में पढ़ने
वाले हैं। यह फंडामेंटल था वीबीए का। अब
मैक्रोस के बारे में हम नेक्स्ट क्लास में
पढ़ने वाले हैं। वीबीए मैक्रोस क्या होता
है? डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट क्या होती है?
Windows हॉटस्क्रिप्ट और आपका इसको
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक के साथ कैसे किया?
क्योंकि सारी चीजें अगर मैं एक साथ कवर
करूंगा सब कुछ खोज हो जाएगा आपका।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है? क्लास में मजा आया? किसी को डाउट है?
किसी को लगता है कि सर समझ में नहीं आया?
बोरिंग था या फिर
सर चेंज करो मजा नहीं आएगा। ऐसा कुछ है
किसी के मन में?
किसी को कोई डाउट
अगर आप लोगों को समझ में आया आप लोगों को
अगर पसंद है आप लोगों को अगर कोई तकलीफ
नहीं हुई क्लास में इजी लग रहा है आपको
लगता है कि नॉलेजेबल है तो प्लीज आप इसको
अपने दोस्तों आप जिनको इसको सच में
रिक्वायरमेंट है सबके साथ शेयर कीजिए,
इनको लाइक कीजिए और कमेंट कीजिए। सो दैट
कि सबको पता चले कि व्हाट टाइप ऑफ
क्वालिटी वी आर डिलीवरिंग।
चलेगा मोहित।
भाई प्रोजेक्ट आपको मैं तभी दे सकता हूं
जब हम चीजें कवर कर लें। हम चीजें कवर कर
लें। जब हम सीटीएफ सॉल्व करेंगे ना सीटीएफ
की जर्नी में फिर से लौटेंगे हम तब आपको
मैं सीटीएफ सॉल्व करने बोलूंगा कि ये
सॉल्व करके लाओ
ओके
तो सॉल्व करके लेके आओ क्योंकि अभी मैं
ऐसे आपको कोई ऐसा कोई रैंडमली क्या
प्रोजेक्ट दूंगा कि एक काम करो आप फलाना
कंपनी को एक सोशल इंजीनियरिंग परफॉर्म
करके दिखाओ बिकॉज़ यह नहीं दे सकता मैं
एक बार सारी चीजें कवर कर लेते हैं
धीरे-धीरे आगे आगे बढ़ जाता है। उसके बाद
सारी चीजों पर हम डिस्कशन करेंगे। पूरा
कोर्स कंप्लीट होने के बाद मैं आपको जहां
पर जुड़ वहां पर मैं दे दूंगा।
किसी को कुछ पूछना है अभी
और कोई किसी को कोई डाउट है तो बताइए।
अदरवाइज हम फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं।
आपका भी टाइम बचेगा। आप भी आपको कुछ और
पढ़ाई करनी हो पढ़ाई कर पाओगे। किसी
दोस्तों के साथ बैठना है बैठ पाओगे या कुछ
और करना कर पाओगे। कोई डाउट है तो बताइए।
अगर नहीं है तो भी बताइए।
क्योंकि आपका
डाउट सेशन ओपन है।
देखेंगे
प्रैक्टिकली
फॉर योर काइंड इनेशन वैसे आपको कहीं नहीं
मिलेगा लेकिन सारी एनुमरेशन आप मैक्रोस से
भी परफॉर्म कर सकते हो बिकॉज़ मैक्रोस
Windows API के साथ क्या करता है? इंटैक्ट
करता है।
कोई नहीं अगर आपकी Gmail की वजह से क्लास
मिस होगी। नो प्रॉब्लम। अभी सेशन एंड हो
जाएगा। अगले एक घंटे में आप इसको देख
लीजिए। आपका रिवीजन हो जाएगा। आपको पता चल
जाएगा क्लास में क्या डिलीवर कर रहा है।
डोंट वरी।
नो प्रॉब्लम मोहित। चलिए फिर अगर कोई आपका
डाउट नहीं है सेशन को एंड करते हैं। तो
बाय-ब एवरीवन।
गुड नाइट एंड टेक केयर। सी यू गाइस।